a new installment in our Raymond on the
road series tonight Raymond Arroyo in
South Bend Indiana now it's home of
mayor Pete Budaj edge but what's the
mayor's real record look like from the
ground from the looks of things you
might think I'm in st. Louis or Detroit
but actually I'm only a few miles from
the golden dome of Notre Dame
welcome to mayor Pete's South Bend
Indiana a place where the local
population here 25% of them lived
beneath the poverty line and crime has
risen to 20-year highs with violent
assaults exceeding by a hundred and
seventy three percent the national
average and there are a lot of abandoned
homes here USA Today recently described
South Bend as one of the most dangerous
cities in America they say it's double
the national and state average for these
assaults why what is happening here
we've got a mayor that's more concerned
about politics right now that is about
public safety in our own City and it's
infuriating because of some of the
rhetoric that mayor Pete employs both
here at home and nationally is it made
it more difficult for you to do your job
and you officers absolutely now the
public sees us as villains they're
looking at at police officers is someone
that wants to hurt them not help them
and morale is at an all-time low as far
as I'm concerned I've been a police
officer here for 27 years this is the
lowest I've ever seen it and it's mainly
due to the mayor's lack of public
support for our officers tell me about
the Eric Logan case that garnered a lot
of national press more than ten officers
have been shot at since that shooting
Wow
that scares off and to what do you
attribute that we attribute that to the
the racism remarks that mayor Pete has
since puing and demoralizing our police
department and the public you know the
public is now afraid to approach us do
you feel safe in South not at all
honestly I can't wait to get out I get
tired of hearing of shootings every
night I feel like I'm on guard I feel
like they try to like cover it up I'm
okay with where I'm at there's some
stuff going on downtown in some other
areas
do you go downtown in South Bend at all
sometimes I do I I used to go a lot but
then it's a lot of fighting I
particularly do not go downtown
especially after late I don't care for
it I don't like it my 15 year old
doesn't like to be out alone at night
either
is there homeless problem absolutely I'm
sure you saw driving over here they're
all over the city
25 percent live below the poverty level
these are their options given what you
witnessed and lived under there Pete's
leadership here is he ready to assume
national office I don't believe so no my
message to the mayor is to drop the
politics and be a leader for the city
that he was swore to be a leader for and
then there's mayor Pete's record on
abortion in 2018 the women's care center
a pro-life crisis pregnancy center
wanted to open up a facility next to
that abortion clinic there the brown
building you're looking at well the City
Council approved their permit but mayor
Pete vetoed it we purchased a building
and our that needed to be resumed we
brought it to the City Council they
approved our rezoning that was vetoed
the owner of the property here where we
stand across this across the street
contacted us and offered us his property
and and so we built here and here we are
serving women and on the west side of
South Bend justice demands and every
woman in this community in every
community across the country has the
opportunity to choose life we're in
downtown South Bend as you can see it's
not exactly populated in the afternoon
but mayor pete has instigated investment
downtown there's some new construction
the Studebaker factory here was recently
turned into a tech hub but the question
is can the residents afford to live in
these new high-rises and apartments I
have two children 24 and 25 I don't
think they could afford to live in some
of those spaces I'm trying to get out of
South Bend currently I don't really see
a lot of opportunity in the city I
definitely feel like it's more for it
those that
money rather than the actual residents
here is mayor peep ready for national
office in your opinion after his record
absolutely not
finally I see him as an opportunist I
don't agree with anything on his
platform
I like mayor Pete I think you would do a
great job and what he's running for and
I support him 100% can't see him
standing toe to toe with Putin there are
some Chinese leaders I personally don't
think he should why not with what he's
done with the city I mean he hasn't
really changed too much and Raymond
Arroyo joins me now
Raymond terrific reporting there what's
your impression of South Bend I've only
been there a couple times because of you
know football games there whatever over
there at Notre Dame buy them though at
least the people you interviewed and
it's not a scientific study or anything
but they seem like he's saying he's not
doing his job at home let alone doing it
for anything for the country well Laura
a lot of these people really like mayor
Pete they think he's smart he's
articulate they give them credit for for
look behind me this new Art Center has
been refurbished but the streets are
empty there's nobody here and this is a
day-long approach to the area it looks
like this it's abandoned it's a ghost
town now the on the other side they say
they feel unsafe they're worried about
rapes they're worried about violent
assaults and not only here in the
neighborhoods and you saw the homeless
problem we uncovered now that's in the
woods but that's here in South Bend and
the the head of the police union there
Harvey Mills shared more information
with us about the drug unit being
shrunken by mayor P as well as traffic
enforcement so we have more to share
with you Laura later in the show they've
sent us a statement the city of South
Bend we've been in touch with mayor
Pete's campaign more to share later in
the show so fantastic alright thank you
so much